Hello. Good afternoon. I'd like to welcome everyone to this mini
symposium on adoptive T cell therapy.
My name is Ryan Moy. I'm an assistant professor at Columbia University.
Hi, everybody. I'm Michele Chou from Fred Hutch Cancer Center.
So I'll provide a brief introduction to adoptive cell therapy.
These are my disclosures.
So adoptive cell therapy has moved from an
experimental in immunology to a transformative therapeutic
platform, and today's talks will highlight how this
field has continued to evolve. In general, adoptive cell
therapy broadly refers to the isolation,
expansion, and/or genetic engineering of a patient's own immune
cells, and then reinfusing them back into the body for enhanced
antitumor immunity. And this can include naturally
tumor-reactive cells, tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes, as well as genetically
modified cells, including chimeric antigen receptor or CAR T
cells, as well as TCR-modified cells.
Over the past decade, there have been seven FDA-approved CAR
products.
This includes for diseases like ALL, large B-cell
lymphoma,
multiple myeloma, and mantle cell lymphoma.
Of note, all of these being hematologic malignancies.
Of course, while several studies have continued to investigate
CAR Ts for solid tumors, there have been additional barriers
and key challenges for developing CAR T cells for solid tumors.
This includes limited accessibility to the tumor site due to dense stroma,
highly immunosuppressive microenvironment, including suppressive
regulatory T cells, myeloid cells, suppressive cytokines like
TGF-beta, as well as antigen heterogeneity and limited
specificity, leading to resistance and off-target toxicity.
In terms of CAR receptors, this includes an
extracellular binding domain, typically an scFv that
recognizes antigen, a transmembrane domain, as well as an
intracellular domain involved in activation of the T cell.
Subsequent generations of CAR receptors have included modifications to
enhance co-stimulation as well as expression of
cytokines leading or armored CAR Ts.
And moreover, there have been several other platforms,
including bivalent receptors,
introduction of
logic gating,
drug switches to turn off CAR T cells to help with
toxicity,
transcriptional rewiring to improve
activity of CAR T cells, reduce exhaustion, and many
others. And so several talks today will touch on different
platforms and ways to enhance CAR activity.
Beyond CAR T cells, which recognize extracellular antigen,
there have been approaches to express specific
T cell receptors in immune cells or
TCR-modified therapy, and this allows for recognition of intracellular
antigens presented on MHC, and we'll hear about
TCR approaches today.
And beyond these genetically engineered approaches, other approaches, as mentioned,
involve expansion of naturally tumor-reactive cells or
tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes.
And this has led to the first approved cellular therapy for solid
tumors being lifileucel
for metastatic melanoma. And today, we'll hear a talk
on autologous TILs for acral
melanoma.
And so beyond a T cell therapy,
a cytotoxic alpha beta T cells, other approaches have looked
at modifying other immune cells. This includes natural killer
cells, macrophages, gamma delta T cells, and
many others. And so we'll hear about CAR dendritic cells today, as well as
NK TCR approaches.
So I'd like to invite up our first speaker today,
Dr. Changsong Qi from Peking University,
to tell us about GPCR engine approach,
iterative engineering of GPCR-targeted synthetic TCRs and antigen
receptor star cells in advanced solid tumors.
Good afternoon, everyone. I'm Dr.
Changsong Qi,
a medical oncologist from Peking University Cancer
Hospital. It's my great honor to have this opportunity to stand
here to share our
translational journey on the iterative engineering of
GPCRs targeted synthetic TCR and antigen receptor
cells in advanced solid tumors.
This is my disclosure.
CAR T cell therapy has achieved remarkable successful in
hematological malignancies, with objective response rate
often exceeding 80%. However, translating this
efficacy to solid tumor has been profoundly
challenging. The efficacy drops significantly
across all known targets in solid
tumors.
As mentioned before, the barriers in solid tumors are
multifaceted. Firstly, we face limited
accessibility to the tumor site due to
discordance-with culture and
dense extracellular matrix. Secondly,
even if T cell infiltrates to the tumor site, they
encounter a highly immunosuppressing
tumor microenvironment characterized by regulatory cells
like MYMPHS, MDSCs, Tregs, and
inhibitory cytokines like TGF-beta,
IL-10.
Thirdly, antigen heterogeneity makes it difficult for CAR T,
which targeting a single target to produce the
curative effect.
To tackle the inherent limitation of conventional CAR T cell
therapy, our collaborators utilized the
STAR T platform. By merging the
targeting domain of the CAR with the natural signaling
complex of a TCR, STAR T cells provide
cytological signaling. This leads four advantages, at
least, TCR like signaling without
tonic signaling and low exhaustion, and high
sensitivity for antigens, deep depleting tumor cells with
low expression of antigen, strong tumor infiltration ability,
and easy for bispecific targeting, which
can broad antigen range to overcome the
heterogeneity.
And GPC3, the ideal tumor-associated antigen
because it is highly expressed in over
70% of
patients with HCC, and impressively in over
95% of AFP positive gastric cancer.
The early clinical trial of GPC3-targeted CAR T cell therapy
had shown antitumor activity in patients with HCC, which
had published in "Nature" 2025. And then
we also select GPC3 as our target on the first
STAR T platform.
We address the solid tumor barriers step by step.
In our first attempt, we armed the STAR T cells with
the chemokine receptor CXCR2 to
actively guide T cells to the tumor.
The tumor microenvironment secretes specific
chemokines like CXCL1, 2,
5, and 8. By engineering our STAR T cells to
express CXCR2, we effectively created
self-driving T cells. STAR T cells armed with
CXCR2 successfully enhanced the tumor trafficking and
localization in our preclinical models.
Driven by this robust preclinical result, we
initiated this first-in-human trial to
translate this science into patient benefit.
We enrolled patients with GPC3-positive advanced solid
tumor who had failed conventional treatment.
Following apheresis, patients received
bridging chemotherapy and standard lymphodepletion chemotherapy prior
to STAR T infusion, and our endpoint was safety and
efficacy mirrored by objective response rate and
progression-free survival.
This is the baseline characteristics for our Version 2
cohort. We treat three heavily pretreated patients
with AFP-positive gastric cancer.
This patient had received up to five prior lines of
treatment, representing a highly refractory
population with significant tumor burdens.
In this Version 2 cohort, we achieved an objective response
rate of 33.3% and a
disease control rate of 66.7%.
However, when we looked at the cellular kinetics, only
the responders exhibited a massive and
sustained expansion of STAR T cells.
In construct, the other patient experienced a rapid
decline in STAR T copy number shortly after infusion.
This critical bedside observation highlights a key problem,
persistence.
To solve this, we went back to the bench.
We designed the Version 3 construct by integrating
membrane-bound IL-15 to provide autonomous survival
signal for durable efficacy.
Our preclinical validation confirmed that arming STAR
T cells with membrane-bound IL-15 lead to
dramatically superior T cell expansion and nearly
completely tumor eradication in vivo,
especially compared to the Version 2 construct.
Then we took the optimized Version 3 construct back to the
clinical. This cohort include four patients, one
with HCC and three with AFP-positive gastric
cancer. Again, these all were
advanced patients who had progressed on multiple prior
treatment.
The addition of membrane-bound IL-15 in Version 3 yield a
clinical improvement. The objective response rate
increased to 15%, and the disease control rate
reached 75%. Most importantly, Version
3 significantly improved the
magnitude of T cell expansion across the cohort.
Well, we have solved the initial expansion hurdle.
Achieving truly long-term persistence remains an active
area in our ongoing clinical
trials.Regarding
safety, the treatments were generally well-tolerated
across all treated patients.
All grade
cytokine release syndrome occurred in
85.7%, with grade three CRIs
at
42.9%.
And we observed only one instance of grade two ICANS,
and two patients experienced grade three
pulmonary injury.
And no treatment-related deaths occurred, and all
adverse events were resolved with standard management.
I'm sorry.
In conclusion,
the iterative step-by-step design of our
GC3 targeted CAR T cell
represents a significant breakthrough.
We achieve a landmark overall
objective response rate of 42.9% in
heavily pre-treated AFP positive GC
and HDCC patients, and we demonstrated a predictive and
manageable safety profile and validated a highly sensitive
platform capable of targeting even low GC3
expression.
At last, I must express my gratitude to the patients and
their families participated in our clinical trial, as well as to
my collaborators and colleagues. Thank you all for your attention.
I would be happy to take any questions.
Thank you. This abstract's now open for questions.
Please come up to the microphone if you have any questions.
I had a question. You noted that there was about
40% grade three CRS rate. How does this compare
to other cellular therapies for solid tumors?
Yeah, it's comparable
to other CAR T-cell therapies in solid tumor.
I'm sorry.
Great talk. I just wanted to
get your idea why your
autologous T-cells doesn't persist that long.
Do you have any
idea why they only persist till two weeks?
Yeah.
Even with IL-15 on it.
This is very critical, I think.
In these four patients,
actually to see the
persistence is limited too. But this clinical
trial is ongoing. I think maybe those
level have affect the
persistence of our CAR T cells.
This may be a
factor.
And did you happen to get any pathology samples and did some
pathologic studies to see these
CAR T cells infiltrating to the tumor region or not?
Do you have any
studies on that?
Yes. Some patients, we do the biopsy and the
rebiopsy before and the post-infusion of the CAR T
cells, but the analysis is
hadn't
to be done. Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you question.
Yep.
Maybe I missed your clinical trial.
Sorry?
Maybe I missed your clinical trial design, but you treat
only four patients with one construct, and then you
switched into the next construct, like an IL-15
membrane bound. So why is it that you haven't
completed this dose escalation and get more complete,
say, safety and then preliminary efficacy data before
going into the next construct?
Yeah. In the
version two cohort, we only enrolled three patients.
Because we look at the cellular
kinetics, we found that the persistence is very limited.
So
we do the
modification to
modify a membrane bound IL-15 version
three.
In the version three cohort,
until now, we enrolled four patients.
But this clinical trial is ongoing.
Do you have a dose escalation for current version
and maybe
also for your version two?
So you use just one dose and treat four patients, and
the trial data didn't look so good, and then-
Yeah
... switched into membrane.
In the version two
cohort, we do not do the escalation of the dose level
because only three patients in the first dose level.
But in the version three, we do the first dose level,
enrolled four patients because one patient had the
toxicity from the
lung infiltration,
so we enrolled another patient to this
cohort.
Okay. Thank you.
Very nice talk. I'm Ming Yu from NIH.
I'm wondering if the circulating chemokines can induce the
exhaustion of the CAR T cells.
Sorry?
Yeah. In the blood, the circulating
chemokines such as CXCL8 can induce the
exhaustion of the CAR T cells because you use the
anti-CXCR2, right?
Yeah.
Yeah.So I was wondering the exhaustion markers of this
kind of CAR T cells.
Sorry, we didn't detect the
markers of the exhausted T cells
in the peripheral blood cell. Yeah.
Oh, thank you.
Okay. Well, I think that's all we have for
time. Thank you, Dr. Qi.
Thank you.
Next, we'll welcome Dr. Qilong Yang from
Tianjin Medical University,
and he will be presenting on "Cellular Architecture of Infused T
Cells Predicts Efficacy of Autologous Tumor-Infiltrating Lymphocyte
Therapy in Acral Melanoma".
Good. Thanks for the introduction. And good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Dr. Qilong Yang from Tianjin Medical University Cancer Hospital from
China. It's my honor to share this
topic on TIL therapy in acral melanoma.
We will talk about our clinical trial results and
the possible mechanism revealed by the
single-cell analysis.
We have no financial disclose.
This
simple roadmap of our talk,
let's begin from the background, and then we'll report our clinical
result. After that, we'll show our
single-cell landscape to determine what's the
mechanism of the response. And finally, we will give some
conclusion and the future directions.
Let's begin from the problem. In Asia, the most
important and common melanoma type is not
the sun-exposed
melanoma, that's the cutaneous melanoma.
But in China and even East Asia, the most type is
acral melanoma. It arise from the fingers, the
toes, and the palms, as quite different from the
cutaneous melanoma. This unique
melanoma has low tumor burden
and mutation burden, and also have different
driver mutation. At the same time, there is a quite
different immuno
microenvironment. These effector induce
this melanoma is response poorly
to standard immunotherapy, such as anti-PD-1 and
anti-CTLA-4 and other immunotherapies.
So that's their unmet critical
need for find new strategies to treat this acral
melanoma. That's what we set out to answer
this question.
One promising approach may be TIL therapy.
We all know that the TIL,
or tumor-infiltrated lymphocyte,
is our own body
immuno cells. These cells can find their own way
into the tumor and find the tumor, kill the tumors.
During the
clinical trials in our labs, we can harvest the
tumor cell pool and expanded the TILs, and
then infuse into the tumor, the patient.
And this method work well in
cutaneous melanoma. But the question is,
how is work in acral melanoma? And
so we want to find these questions.
So we set up a small
investigator-initiated clinical trial in Chinese patient.
We enrolled four Chinese AM patients, who
processed on previous treatment such as
immunotherapy, chemotherapy, and targeted therapy.
Also we
collect the tumor cells and manufacture
a TIL products we called
LM103.
And then after a few phases of
chemotherapy to make more room for the new cells, we
infuse these
TIL products into the patient and see what's the
response. Also, that's the
overview of the design. Most importantly, we collect
the samples from the tumor cell samples,
also collect the samples from the TIL products
and the patient's blood with RNA
sequencing and TCR sequencing to find what's the mechanism
is.
The result is interesting, and we can see
there's the DCR rate is
75. That means three
of four patients had their tumor stop or
shrink clearly.
One patient, patient four, achieve a
long time durable response from the TIL therapy.
We can see her tumor stopped growth and
shrink clearly,
showed by the CT scan and the physical examination.
That's a clinical
significance close that the TIL
therapy is effective and have
clinical utility in the future.
So we want to know
what does this TIL therapy works in
acral melanoma. So we collect
over 100,000
cells from the tumor
tissue and the TIL products and the
peripheral blood.And these give us an
integrated single-cell analysis of the immune
response.
We found something interesting. Panel C, we can see
that
about more than 90% of the
T cell in the TIL products,
this confirms the successful expansion of
our TIL products. And also we can see
in panel C, we can see a complete responder show the significantly
higher
90% cells in 12-week PBMC
over the low T cell fraction in the stable disease
patient. It's most important because it
shows that possess the T cell-based immunity correlated with the
durable clinical response.
But not all the T cell created equal, so
we zoomed into the T cell and the NK cell
to see what of the type of the cells is
expanded. Here we
collect over
500,000
NK and T cells, and classed them. And we find that
there are several types include naive, Treg,
TFH, and exhausted CD8 T cells
in
TIL products.
Also, we use a method called zero-time analysis.
We can check the path of T
cell expansion exhaust.
The arrow show the direction of the T cell development.
It starts from the
progenitor exhaust T cell, and then move to the
intermediate exhaust T cells. Then these cells
take a fork in the road.
Either they become a more effective CD8
exhaust cells or become terminal
exhausted T cells. We know that these cells can't find the
tumor anymore because they lost their a lot of cell
markers and can't do
kill the tumor cells. This distinction is very
important because
the T cell type determines the clinical
response, not the total T cells
quantity.
Also, we want to know which of these states in the
responder and the non-responder.
Here we can see in the responder, most of the T cell is
the effect and intermediate exhausted T
cells. However,
in the non-responder, most of the T cell is a
terminal
exhausted T cells. These cells can't find the tumor anymore.
Compared to all the Tx exhaust cells, we can
see in the PD patient, most of the
T cell is a terminal
exhausted T cells. Compared to this,
in the response patient, most of the cell,
three important cell population.
That's the effector and intermediate exhaust T
cells and the TFH cell.
So
also, this
important significance that
the T cells
quality is most important. Also we
can see in the complete responder, there are
unique maintain the
progenitor T
cells in
her blood 12 weeks.
So we want to know, why is this TFH cell doing
here?
And we see that we use a method called cell-cell
communication. And we found most
signal
is supplied by the CD4 TF, the
follicular help T cells. And most the
CD8
intermediate exhausted T cell was the receiver of the
signals. At the same time, we see the
pathways changes, and we can see in the responder,
most of the signal is the co-stimulatory
pathways, which drive T cell activation and survival.
Well, in non-responder, that is
characterized by the immunosuppressive pathways such as
CD137, TGF-beta pathways,
indicating there is a failed immunocoordination.
We can see these pathways changed.
This bring us to a clone level.
Generally, we see T cells can be sort of clones.
We can check the
expansion that the T cell, the exhaustion, and to know
which one is expansion.
From here, we can see most large and
expansion clone here, that large expansion clone
concentrate right on the TFH and the intermediate
exhausted T cells. Well, the
sparse and the scattered
expansion for the non-responders.
So that means largely
the clones
number and the diversity may be correlation with the
response.Also, we can see clone
dominance is persistent. Complete response, maintain
stable high clonalities in peripheral
blood even after 12 weeks. And at the
same time, we can see there's
the other patient, the repertory contract.
Also, we can see in the responder, there is a higher
clonality diversity and the spectral organization at the
TCR repertory in the responder.
Here where we find the mechanism for
durability. Here we can see the infused, the
intermediate exhaust T cell successfully
engraft and differentiate into progenitor cell in
peripheral blood, even after 12
weeks. It's a direct evidence for in vivo lineage
transition and self-renew capacity.
It's a blueprint for the durable immunity.
Because these clone expanded
intermediate exhaust T cells express persistent
progenitor reserve through the
differentiation, continuously replenishing antitumor
immunity, and clarify cellular basis for
sustained clinical response in our trial.
So what's the result? From our data, we find
the follicular helper CD4 T cell
and the
intermediate exhaust T cell-centered immuno
ecosystem drive the durable response in the TIL
therapy. Here we can see that's the intermediate exhaust
T cell, and can transfer,
came to the progenitor. Then they
can move to intermediate and the effector
exhaust T cells and to fight the tumor and kill the tumor.
So to summarize, the first, the TIL therapy
is active, is worked in acral
melanoma. We have clinical proof.
Second, the production quality is more
important than the quantity because the efficacy is
derived by the TFH and the intermediate
exhaust T cells, not the total T cell numbers.
And
the third, the durable immunity comes from the
progenitor exhaust T cells, because
it's seeded by the infused TIL cells in clones.
And the last, we have
actionable biomarkers to predict and monitor
the clinical response in the TIL therapy.
So what's next? Right now, we also set up a Phase II
clinical trial to evaluate the acral melanoma
compared with select chemotherapies.
And also in the future, we already use a new
tool called T-editor, do the CRISPR
mid technology for the TIL
gene editor. And, also we have finished this.
Our preliminary data also shows that this
supercharged TIL product overcomes the
immuno response of TGF-beta signaling in tumor
microenvironment.
The data shows that the supercharged TIL
product can produce much more
interferon gamma and
increase the cytolytic activity.
In animal model, we also can see the
LM030 can increase
the tumor growth inhibition.
So in the future, maybe we'll have three methods to
optimize our TIL therapy. First, we can
optimize the manufacturers,
the TIL therapy products, because we can use small
molecular and cytokines and such things
to make a more optimized products.
Also, we need to find more
good or easily to find biomarkers to predict
or monitor the response. And also we need to
validate these biomarker in the perspective
studies in the future. Also, we can produce more
next generation TIL product to overcome the
immuno resistance in
other solid tumors.
So this is group work and
thanks very much to the Professor Xin Chen and Professor
Xiangkun Li's group, also my colleagues in Tianjin Cancer
Hospital. Thank you for the attention.
Due to time, I think we're going to hold questions to the end, but thank you very
much for a really great talk.
I'd like to invite up our next speaker.
Thank you.
I'd like to invite up Dr. Carl Desomme from Washington University
School of Medicine in St. Louis, and he'll be presenting on a novel
first in class chimeric antigen receptor dendritic cell platform driving
broad and durable antitumor immunity in solid tumors.
All right. Well, thank you so much for the opportunity to speak here.
So, the goal of this project, like many projects, is to try to
make difficult cancers more curable.
And I'll talk about a little bit of the limitations of current immune therapies.
The last patient right here is a patient we treated on a Phase I trial with CAR T
cells, ALL, and they had a great response for a while, and then a year later, they
regressed. They progressed and regressed and eventually died.
So I'll talk about the limitations of current cell therapies and other immune
therapies, and then talk about CAR DC1s, which is a
newer method for combining the precision of CAR engineering with
dendritic cell immune orchestration, and then talk a little bit about the
manufacturing of this new type of cell
therapy.So CAR T cells we know
encounter many limitations in solid tumors. One of them is antigen escape.
If there's antigen negative tumor cells, then those eventually progress, and there
are almost always antigen negative tumor cells in solid tumors, and that alone
accounts for many of the lack of complete responses we see in
solid tumors, I think.
When you think about PD-1 inhibitor therapy,
the
anti-PD-1 therapy requires activated tumor reactive T cells in the
beginning for those
PD-1 inhibitors to work upon, and specifically those in a stem-like state or a PEC
state. And it's really unclear how to generate these T cells in a patient who does
not already have them, and especially antigen-specific stem-like T cells.
But we do know from mouse studies that they require priming by DC1s.
So DC1s are really the generals of the immune system.
They create T cell responses and B cell responses, and they do
that primarily by sensing infected
cells. Over evolution, they've really evolved to
detect infected cells, and they take up those infected fragments,
migrate to draining lymph nodes, and then cross prime T cells, create memory, and
affect your cells that way.
They can also do this in cancer, but one glaring difference in cancer is that tumor
cells don't express the pattern recognition receptors that an affected cell
has. So there is nothing that distinctively tells a dendritic
cell that a tumor is a foreign cell that needs to be reacted
upon. So we thought this was a good opportunity for a chimeric antigen
receptor. Unfortunately, it took a long time to engineer type one dendritic
cells. It turns out they're very hard to engineer.
But we eventually were able to identify CARs that
expressed very highly on the surface of these cells.
And for the dendritic cell aficionados, this is what they look like.
They're really type one dendritic cells, XCR1 high, SIRPalpha low.
And these are delivered with an mRNA, so it's a non-integrating technology.
It's structured like a normal CAR antibody domain linker, transmembrane signaling
domain, and then a cleavage site with a co-expression marker of Thy1.1.
We're targeting B7-H3 as the tumor antigen here because it's on a wide range of
solid tumors. And then for controls, we have the binding only domain, which
doesn't have the signaling domain, and then Thy1 alone.
And we've tested a number of different signaling domains.
I'm going to talk about the TLR4 signaling domain because it's really a receptor
that recognizes infections and has a robust response
against infections normally.
So first we noticed that when we engineer these DC1s with a CAR, with the TLR4
signaling domain, they take up more antigen.
So if you
express OVA, that's AF488 labeled in the tumor,
co-culture them
with these CAR DC1s, you see greater uptake of OVA
from the tumor. The binding only DCs also take up more.
So just forcing the interaction between the DC1 and the tumor
allows the DCs to acquire more antigen, but more is required when there's
TLR4 signaling.
And more dramatically, the costimulatory program is
really strongly driven by TLR4 signaling.
So with the binding only DCs, as you would imagine, they don't have any
signaling domain. They don't induce expression of
things like CCR7, 4-1BB ligand, CD86, CD70.
However, the TLR4 signaling CARs really induce a strong
costimulatory program across many different costimulatory
molecules.
Now in vitro, we do this cross-priming assay, which is a really nice assay to look
for the ability of the DC to cross-prime tumor reactive T cells.
And for these we use oval loaded tumor that expresses B7H3.
It has MHC-1 knocked out on its own cells, so it can't directly
stimulate T cells. And so the only way to stimulate these OT-1
T cells is through antigen uptake and then
processing and presentation on the DC's own MHC-1.
And then we look at proliferation and activation.
And we like to also do this with wild type T cells because ideally we don't want to
activate all T cells in the body. We don't want to create toxicity.
We really want to activate the tumor specific T cells, which is a really hard thing
to do.
So when you look at this
proliferation, which is CTV here, and then CD44 expression, which is a
measure of activation, the wild type T cells in this circumstance get very
minimally activated. But the tumor specific T cells are very, very substantially
activated. This is a three-day assay.
And when you quantify this, you can see 1,000-fold
increase in the activation of tumor specific T cells versus wild type T
cells.
And the normal DCs, Thy1 DCs, binding only
DCs, have a very, very small
activity compared to the CAR DCs. So if you blew up the access, this would be a
significant difference, but it's not nearly as big as the CAR.
So jumping ahead into solid tumor models.
So this is a sarcoma, MCA-induced sarcoma syngeneic model, BL6
mice, and 75% of the tumor cells here express
B7H3. 25% of them are B7H3 negative.
So we do this to model the heterogeneity seen in patients.
And there's no exogenous tumor antigens here, so there's no OVA, there's no
overexpressed antigen that
makes it easier for T cells to eliminate.
And so when we treat these with Thy1 mRNA modified
DCs, you get
a couple of rejections out of 30 mice.
Binding only DCs do a little bit better of a job, but
the TLR4 signaling CAR DCs really have a pretty
striking complete rejection rate, 30 out of 30 mice.
And I think this is when we first started to think this is potentially going to be
a
great way to possibly treat solid tumors if we can harness this,
especially in the clinical setting.
So when we
take these mice that have been cured and we re-inject them with new tumor 100 days
later, so far after the time that the DCs are gone, if we re-inject a
B7H3 positive tumor or B7H3 negative tumor, you get a
similar rejection of the tumor late on.
So there's long-term memory, and that memory is against antigens that are not the
CAR targets. Remember, the CAR DC is targeting B7H3, but it creates a T
cell response against non-B7H3
antigens.So we wanted to know these antigens that are
reacting, and the T cells that are reacting to these antigens, how is this working?
We looked at OVA, but we all know OVA is a artificial antigen, it
has a high affinity TCR. You can overexpress at high levels.
So what happens to the endogenous tumor antigens?
So to answer this, we did a
number of mass spec analyses where we looked at the cross-presented
peptides on CAR DC1s and elute the
MHC-1 peptides and quantify them
by mass spec to identify what are the peptides that are actually being
cross-presented by CAR DC1's endogenous peptides.
And this is a log 2 scale, but you can see that the total cross-presented
peptide abundance is far greater with CAR DC1s compared to the
binding-only DCs
and compared to the Thy1 DCs. So just like the OVA experiments,
they do cross present a large amount of peptides, and many of those
peptides are actually unique. So these are peptides that are not cross-presented
at all by normal DCs. So this potentially
allows the DCs to create T cell responses that weren't potentially
there with normal DC responses.
When you look at the individual peptides, you can see that a
normal DC cross-presents peptides from the tumor at a wide array
of levels. Many of them are at very low levels.
The CAR DC really cross-presents peptides at a very high level, almost across the
board. 90% of the peptides here are cross-presented at a level that's higher than
the average DC is cross-presenting peptides.
So you get not only a larger repertoire, but a higher abundance
and expression of these cross-presented peptides.
So this tells us a number of things are cross-presented, but it doesn't actually
tell us are any of these cross-presented peptides actually creating T cell
responses and are these T cell
responses being affected by the CAR DC?
Is the phenotype of those T cells changing?
A lot of those questions we then sought to answer with a number of other
experiments that I'll try to condense down to a couple slides here.
But so the first question is, new epitopes
are easiest to look at because we know that they're not present in normal tissues.
So if we can find new antigen-specific responses, then those are
easiest to track. So we took our sarcoma, and
we predicted new antigens, new epitopes, and we
found 176 predicted antigens that could bind MHC-1 within the
tumor. When we actually did mass spec on the tumor cells, we only could find
three of these new antigens were actually expressed by the tumor cells on their
own MHC-1.
So then we looked at the CAR DCs, and we found that they cross-presented
all three of those neoantigens. And the first
neoantigen is here. You can see the binding-only DCs cross-presented it very
poorly. CAR DCs cross-presented it much better.
The second of these was cross-presented pretty poorly by both of them.
And then third was cross-presented fairly highly by both of them.
So we decided this is a neoantigen we would look at, and it was
cross-presented at similar levels in the wild-type DCs and the CAR DCs.
So we wanted to know, are there actual T cells reacting to that
neoantigen? What is the phenotype of those T cells?
So we used that neoantigen to make tetramers, and then we stained
the TILS for T cells that react against
that. And we found that indeed there are T cells that react against this
neoantigen, and indeed, the CAR DCs
increase the number of TILS that are responsive to this neoantigen,
both in the tumor and in the spleen.
Consistent with the idea that the T cells are being primed in the lymph
node and then circulating systemically, taking up residence in the spleen and also
going to the tumor. When we looked at the
phenotype of these
tumor-specific T cells, we noticed that they were all different.
They were also different from that of T cells
primed by wild-type dendritic cells.
So in particular, they expressed low tox and high
PD-1, and this is this transitory effector cell that was actually just discussed in
the last talk.
And this is an interesting population because it's in many different studies shown
to be a very important population for T cell mediated tumor
killing and lasting immune responses.
We also know from the literature that this population generally comes from a
stem-like T cell population, and that stem-like T cell population generally lives
outside of the tumor where there's no antigen.
So we looked at the tumor-draining lymph nodes and the
phenotype of the T cells there. And consistent with that, we see very high
expression of things like TCF1, TCF7, this gene,
SLAMF6, IL7 receptor, Bcl-2. And this is
really generating a stem-like T cell signature within the tumor-draining lymph
node.
So the CAR DC1s are not only generating more tumor-reactive T cells, they're also
generating a stem-like population in the tumor-draining lymph node.
And these stem-like T cells are known to be
able to continuously repopulate the tumor with
new waves of effector cells. So to test that functionality here, we
took those tumor-draining lymph nodes, the CD8 T cells from the tumor-draining
lymph nodes, and then injected them into new Rag mice that had tumor and
looked for the ability of these progenitors that had produced a
wave of response in the primary tumor to produce a new wave of response
in the secondary tumor. And if you do this in untreated mice,
just for reference, you get very few clones that can
repopulate or create these recall competent T cells.
Most of them cannot continuously repopulate the tumor with new effector cells.
We also labeled these with cell trace violet.
So we know that 100% of these cells have proliferated, so
they weren't the cells we actually transferred, but these are the progeny.
So this is the original tumor. And after CAR DC1 treatment,
most of these tumor-draining T cells
can produce new progeny that continuously
reinfiltrate the tumor. So you can see also the numbers,
but the repertoire is affected. When we look back at the
neoantigen-specific T cell repertoire, you can see that there's both a
greater diversity and a greater number of these antigen-specific T
cells.And I want to go back and just point out that
these are just T cells that react against a single neoantigen.
So there's over 100 different clones that recognize this
single neoantigen. This is only one antigen out of all of
these that was cross-presented by the CAR DC1.
So when we think about antigen heterogeneity and overcoming that, I think
that this is potentially explaining why we get this very nice response
against heterogeneous tumors.
So limitation of current cell therapy, single antigen targeting
inevitably leads to resistance in many cases.
This is an ability to enable
multi-antigen capture and cross-presentation to T cells.
It's a way to orchestrate the full cancer immune cycle,
as you can see in the T cell phenotype in the repertoire that develops.
And we think that this is particularly well designed to treat solid tumors,
although it could certainly be a liquid tumor treatment as well.
So the next
big process in this whole
many year project was really trying to create a human CAR
DC1 therapy. DC1s have traditionally been hard to generate in large numbers
in human cells, so we utilized this
AI-enabled synthetic agonist method that allows us to create
a cocktail of
synthetic cytokines that really
pretty potently commit human hematopoietic stem cells to the conventional
DC1 lineage. And we do this in a closed system in conjunction
with Fisher Scientific and are able to manufacture
over 300 million CAR DC1s per run. And this is a clinical
grade production process that's scalable and ready for the GMP
setting. What it can mean for patients, obviously, is
we could potentially treat tumors that are resistant to current therapies,
eliminate tumors more completely, reduce relapse, create
long-term protection, and expand to cell types that are B7-H3 positive,
of which there are many solid tumor cell
types that have a high expression B7-H3, and conceivably other
antigens should work too. We
just are pursuing B7-H3 at the moment.
The program status currently in the path forward,
so the first in human clinical trial is funded and planning for
2027, and we'll start out with intra-tumoral delivery
as a safety phase and then move to IV delivery, which we've also done in mice as
well and is the goal of the therapy in the long run.
It's currently being advanced completely within the academic center, but we think
it's also
potentially a useful strategic partnering
opportunity if we want to potentially expand the platform.
Right now we're seeking to treat a select few group of
malignancies.
So I'd like to thank the people who do the work in this lab,
and then our collaborators and our funders and
collaborators at Fisher for the human translational product as well.
And I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thank you, Dr. Dassome. In interest of time, we'll hold
questions and move on to the next talk.
I mean, afterwards, if you have any thoughts.
All right. Next we'll welcome Dr. Sabine
Heiteneider from Stanford University, and she'll be
discussing "Decoding the Medulloblastoma
Serpinosome Prioritizes the
Oncofetal Antigen GPC2 for Potent CAR T
Cell Therapy."
Thank you very much for the kind introduction.
That was an excellent pronunciation of my last name.
I'm excited to have this opportunity today to speak to you about our
hunt for ideal target antigens for childhood solid tumors
and brain tumors for CAR T cell therapy.
Okay, these are my disclosures.
So today we really have a clear and growing body of evidence that CAR T
cells can mediate significant clinical
responses in solid tumors and brain tumors.
And to name just a few example, IL-15 armored GPC3
CAR T cells have been reported to
mediate clinical activity in a trial at Texas
Children's.
The Locatelli Group in Italy has reported a 33% complete response
rate in recurrent and refractory neuroblastoma with GD2 CAR T
cells, and our very own institution has written a tremendous
success story of GD2 CAR T cells
in patients with diffuse midline glioma, which is a very aggressive
childhood brain tumor.
And 36% of patients in this trial have experienced tumor volume
reductions of more than 50%, and this included a complete
response that is now actually ongoing for more than four years.
So I think
the time really has passed where CAR T cells are only
applicable for hematologic malignancies, but we still
have barriers to overcome.
So what are some of the key factors to this success?
One that my lab is thinking about extensively are tumor
antigens that in solid tumors and brain tumors can be
targeted with high potency without normal tissue
liability. And one compelling
approach to look for them is to simply take data sets from
all healthy tissues throughout the body and pediatric cancer tissues, and
then simply ask the question, "What's really high on the tumor and what's not on
normal tissues?"
And specifically in childhood cancer, I think we have a compelling opportunity
here due to its prenatal origin. So a lot of childhood
cancers actually resemble fetal transcriptional programs,
and some of the oncogenic events occur during fetal development.
So in that sense, childhood cancers are poised to express
oncofetal antigens that are expressed in developing tissues but then get shut
down at birth, and they represent a compelling opportunity for potent and
safe CAR T targeting.So we did a principal
components analysis, and we looked at pediatric tumor
transcriptomes and compared them to prenatal
healthy brain tissues. And we found that specifically CNS and branul
tumors with ETMR and medulloblastoma here
leading the rank,
closely resemble
prenatal brain tissues.
So we
attempted to decode the surfaceome of medulloblastoma and did a
differential gene expression analysis from transcriptomes of tumors
compared to normal tissues using cell surface filtration, and we found
several significantly upregulated genes in medulloblastoma.
This analysis ranked GPC2 or glypican 2 as the top
candidate, and it actually scored significantly higher than several
other antigens that have been previously described as CAR T targets in
medulloblastoma.
We also identified four additional targets that are compelling
candidates that pass these three predefined filters to look for
suitable CAR antigens.
And interestingly, they actually all follow this oncofetal expression pattern,
where they're expressed at high levels in prenatal tissues but then get shut down
prior to birth.
GPC2 is one antigen that was discovered by surfaceome
profiling of neuroblastoma at the Children's Hospital of Philadelphia.
And when we looked at the transcriptional profiles
during human organ development, we found that GPC2 is a prototypical
oncofetal antigen. So it's expressed at high levels in the developing brain
and cerebellum but gets shut down prior to birth.
This is also resembled in prenatal brain sections, where the
expression of GPC2 declines over time with gestational age,
but it stays high in neuroblastoma tumor sections.
So when we set out to engineer CAR T cells, first,
I attempted to measure the actual antigen density on clinical samples of
neuroblastoma metastatic to the bone marrow and found that they
express only moderate levels of GPC2, so only 5,000 molecules per
cell. And so specifically using these preclinical models
that resemble clinical levels of GPC2, we observed
that CD28-derived transmembrane domains were necessary
to render CAR T cells potent against these clinically relevant
levels of antigen.
And our lead candidate also has a CD28
costimulatory domain to further improve
the antigen detection threshold.
We found that this led to impressive antitumor activity in
preclinical models of neuroblastoma.
However, we found a small fraction of tumors that ended up
recurring after a prolonged interval of cure.
And this was associated with a drop in GPC2 antigen density.
And so to address this problem, we utilized a method that was developed in
Chris Romero's lab and overexpressed the AP1 transcription
factor c-Jun,
which was shown to not only be able to render CAR T cells
exhaustion-resistant, but also further lower the antigen detection
threshold. And this approach indeed mitigated this
antigen-low tumor escape.
In medulloblastoma, GPC2 is expressed at high levels in
transcriptomes across all molecular subgroups.
It's expressed in clinical
specimens of fixed tissue sections skewed towards Group 3 and Group
4, which are the more aggressive subtypes.
We find it in medulloblastoma cell lines, and next developed an
antigen density quantification method to actually measure the
molecules per cell found on medulloblastoma tumor resections,
and compared that to several other target antigens that have been
considered for targeting medulloblastoma.
We found that very similar to our computational pipeline,
thyrotropin receptor alpha, EPHA2, and HER2 only showed limited
expression in clinical samples.
B7H3 was highly prevalent on tumor cells.
However, the antigen density was on the lower end, with
less than 10,000 molecules per cell in the clinical samples.
For GD2, we actually saw an interesting trend where
it was very heterogeneous on cell lines, but we found a high and homogeneous
expression in clinical samples.
And for GPC2, we also found high fractions of antigen-positive tumor
cells with an average of more than 6,000 molecules per cell on the
tumor cell surface, which is above the detection threshold of our previously
engineered CAR T constructs.
We also looked for the stemness marker CD133
and its relationship to antigen-positive tumor cells within
the tumor resections.
And interestingly, we found that GPC2-positive tumor cells in clinical
samples contained a higher fraction of CD133-positive
cells.
Those also expressed higher levels of antigen density of
GPC2, which was not observed for B7H3 or GD2.
We then were wondering if these GPC2 high fractions actually
exhibit higher self-renewal capacities and
flow sorted them into high and low populations and found that the GPC2
high population actually was able to
show an increased formation of tumor spheres.
Next, we were wondering about the molecular pathways driven by
GPC2 and knocked it out of several medulloblastoma cell lines and
performed RNA sequencing and found that GPC2 was associated
with a neural progenitor signature.
So all of this suggesting that GPC2 CAR T cells might mediate
improved clinical benefit by also targeting higher fractions of
tumor-initiating stem cells.
Next, we were curious to understand the potential of our previously
engineered CAR T cells
across different levels of antigen
densities and found that those overexpressing c-Jun consistently
mediated higher levels of interferon gamma and IL-2
against medulloblastoma cell lines.We then partnered with Sheila Singh's
lab at McMaster to exploit her
compelling
orthotopic xenograft models in order to further
understand how GPC2 antigen density relates to
potency in vivo.
And we established a new patient-derived
xenograft model
from a patient with Group 4 medulloblastoma that very closely resembles the levels
we found on clinical resections. And we found that in this model, both
CAR T-cells mediated potent
antitumor controls.
So next, we turned to a faster-growing model, also Group
4, and again found that both constructs mediated complete responses in this
model.
So for a clinical efficacy, we really need to be able to target more
aggressive models of tumors. So we turned to a
Group 3 medulloblastoma model that is GPC2 high, and
it has been derived from a patient with a MYCN amplified
recurrent disease at an autopsy time point, and this
model really is not responsive to standard of therapy
at all.
A single dose of GPC2 CAR T-cells mediates
potent antitumor control. However, improved responses are seen when we
keep dosing with more doses of CAR T-cells or with a single
dose of CDTR1 overexpressing CAR T-cells.
This also led to an improved survival in these mice and came with an increased
persistence for both the multiple infusion and the single dose of
CDTR1 CAR T-cell group.
Interestingly, we found that
those mice that stopped responding to a single dose of GPC2 CAR
T-cells
that at the endpoint had a similar tumor burden than the control mice
actually showed a limited spread of tumor cells to the leptomeninges,
indicating that GPC2 CAR T-cells could potentially
limit the metastatic spread.
On the basis of these results, we recently opened a Phase 1 clinical
trial, excuse me
with this construct that is optimized for clinically relevant levels of antigen
density.
We enroll patients with GPC2 positive confirmed disease,
medulloblastoma, and other ultra-rare CNS embronal tumors.
So far, we have screened 17 patients and found that about 60% of those
meet the eligibility criteria based on their
expression of GPC2 in the tumor.
This would all not be possible without my wonderful partner in crime, Katie Ryan,
who's the clinical PI on this study, and Crystal Mackall is the IND holder.
Our Phase 1 study design is that patients get
lympho-depleting chemotherapy and then locoregional CAR-T
delivery using an intra-patient dose escalation,
where every 28 days, they receive a dose of CAR T-cells.
And we also have an extensive correlative pipeline to look at predictors of
toxicity and response.
So far, we've enrolled four patients,
and they've received up to six infusions.
And even though this is all very early, we do see early signs of feasibility and
safety in this trial. The maximum toxicity we've
observed is a Grade 2 TN,
and we haven't seen any dose-limiting toxicities despite the fact that we
can detect these CAR T-cells in the CSF by flow cytometry
in patients.
Questions about the trial, please reach out at
gpc2cart@stanfordchildrens.org.
And I hope that I have shown you today that the prenatal origin of childhood
cancer represents a compelling therapeutic opportunity for adoptive cell
therapy to target oncofetal antigens, which represent
the main target pool in medulloblastoma,
with GPC2 ranking as the top candidate.
That antigen density of GPC2 in clinical specimens
exceeds CAR-T detection thresholds,
that GPC2 positive tumor cells contain higher
fractions of CD133 positive cells and are
associated with higher self-renewal capacities.
That CDTR1 overexpression does lower the antigen detection thresholds and improves
persistence in long-term antitumor control,
and that early data of an ongoing GPC2
CAR T-cell trial shows signs of feasibility and safety in CNS
embronal tumors. With that said, I'd like to thank the giant village.
Without this work would not be possible,
and I'm happy to take questions.
I think we have time for maybe one question.
I have a question. So you're doing
locoregional CAR T-cell administration, but you're giving
lymphodepletion prior to that.
Yes.
Do you mind kind of explaining the rationale behind that?
Sure. So a lot of the clinical trial design is based on
our institutional experience with administering GD2 CAR T-cells
for patients with diffuse midline glioma.
And we have seen advances with lymphodepleting chemotherapy,
even though we give them prior to
locoregional CAR-T delivery.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
I'd like to invite Dr. Rafet Bassar
up from MD Anderson Cancer Center.
He'll be talking about NK TCR cells, a next generation
platform expanding NK cell therapeutic potential.
Thank you.
Good afternoon. Thank you for the invitation and for this opportunity to present
our novel platform around TCR engineering NK
cells. Today, I will try to update our preclinical work
and the patient that we have treated, some response, and
then I'm going to go on. Thank you.
So this is basically what we are doing.
We're trying to combine TCR
precision with the NK cell cytotoxicity machinery,
which will retain NK cell,
the native pathway killing capacity such as
DNAM, NKG2D,
and NCR receptor. Further, we arm with IL-15 in
order to
improve the persistent in vivo expansion and antitumor activity of
NK cells. Given that NK cells without IL-15, they're going to have
short lifespan.
So this is the overview, how we're generating this NK TCR.
We're using the cord blood
NK cell. We're isolating from the cord blood, and then we're giving
expanding one round of expansion with the feeder cells
alongside with IL-2. And then around day six, day seven, we
introduce
with the vector that we're interested,
in this case, is going to be TCR and the CD3.
And then, after another round of expansion to get enough
number of cells, we cryopreserve cells and make the
off-the-shelf product. When patient need it, then we can go
ahead and infuse into the patients.
This bringing, preventing the
manufacturing failure, but also bringing down the cost
that we can spend on each product. And of course,
this is going to be also the big advantage is going to make suitable
for outpatient delivery.
So this work is leading by Dr. Bin Lu in our Cell Therapy
Institute, and he generated these two vectors that we
can make this
platform. One is going to be CD3 that we can get all
part of CD3, including beta, delta, gamma, and
zeta, alongside with IL-15. And then for
antigen-specific TCR, we have another vector.
Whatever antigen that we're interested, we can
produce and then integrate with these CD3 constructs.
So as you can see, on the right side, we can successfully transduce NK
cells with these two product at the same times, which we
can, with flow cytometry, we can show with the CD3 and TCR
alpha/beta.
So first we went after the two well-established
antigen that is available, and then many clinical trial is going on
with the TCR T cells, which are PRAME and
NY-ESO-1. And you can see here across many
tumor, they have the strong and selective expression,
including melanoma, sarcoma, leukemia, and
myeloma. And then just given that they have
less in normal tissue expression, high on the tumor expression,
we went after that and we generate the PRAME and NY-ESO-1
TCR NK cells. So we did number
of in vitro, in vivo experiment. With in vitro, we tested
with different
setup of tumor, including sarcoma for NY-ESO-1.
You can see one spheroid assay that we either treated...
We did untreated or treated with NY-ESO TCR
NK cells, and you can see just they're showing strong antitumor
activity. And as well as with the multiple myeloma,
which we know, and there is clinical trial with the TCR T cells
NY-ESO-1, and show, again, really high
antitumor activity. But what's really important here, we need to make
sure that we're not going to cause any off-target activity.
To test that, we have this LCL, this
antigen-presenting cell that NK cell, they're not going to show any antitumor
activity. But when you have a peptide that you can pulse
this LCL and make bridge between NK cells and these
antigen-presenting cells, then you can activate the NK cell, and then you can
kill. You can see when you have
no
peptide and then co-culture NK cell with this LCL, they're not going
to show any antitumor activity. This is reassuring that your NK
TCR is not going to cause any off-target toxicity.
In the presence of a peptide, you're seeing just when you have a
bridge between this NK TCR and LCL, they show strong antitumor
activity.
And the same as the in vitro data, we have it here with the PRAME TCR.
Again, we use against the melanoma and AML in this case.
And with the both, you can see just really strong antitumor activity,
spheroid assay that we did with Incucyt for PRAME TCR NK cells.
And again, for Incucyt assay, you're showing really
good antitumor activity against the AML cell line that we use
in this case. And we did reassuring with off-target
toxicity. Again, we use the PRAME peptide
here also just to combine with co-culture with the
LCL and show that again, NK TCR, they're not showing
any off-target toxicity.
So
here one important things why we need selected
this platform I want to show we did the single cell killing
assay by collaboration with Dr. Nevin Vadakkan in
UH.
And we compare TCR T cell and TCR NK cells.
On the left side, you're seeing just when I show here the TCR T
cells,
is taking around five minutes to engage, eliminate the tumor,
single tumor from the well.You can see
this is going on.
It's around six minutes total. But in contrast, TCR NK cell,
they're showing us this antitumor activity much faster.
And we also observed that they can kill
two tumors less than two minutes. This is
just reassuring that they're not just faster, but they demonstrate
rapid serial killing as well. This also
showing and then highlighting one more time the key
advantage combining TCR precision with
NK cell cytotoxicity machinery.
So we did some in vivo experiment with both NY-ESO-1 and
pre-TCR NK cell. With both models, we use
myeloma, and then after engrafting a tumor with
the myeloma cell line, a week later, we treat it with TCR NK cell,
or we left them untreated. In both models, you can see strong
antitumor activity, which really prolonged survival.
So the other things we need to make sure that this NK TCR, they're not going
to cause any off-target toxicity in our mouse model,
and then we need to make sure they engraft, persist, and they also traffic to
tumor site. Again, we use the myeloma mice model,
and after engrafting with the myeloma cell line, seven days
later, we treat it with NK TCR, and then we look at the first
survival engraftment and the tumor NK cell trafficking.
And you can see here,
you show really strong
antitumor activity without evidence when you
measure with the BLI and a prolonged survival.
Out of all five mice actually cure, and
we just retired these mice.
And then we look at the engraftment of this NK cell at day
10, day 20. You can see really good engraftment of this NK cell in
the peripheral blood without causing any toxicity that we have
special scoring that we score these mice, but
also just checking with the weight of...
Following with the weight of these mice.
The important things from this experiment also, you can see
really good engraftment of NK cell in bone marrow, which is a main
site for myeloma, and in the spleen, really good population of NK
cells.
So and then we went after this all in vitro and in vivo
experiment, we designed the clinical trial, and we
made the bio NK cell bank,
and we conduct two clinical trial that is leading by Dr.
Muzaffer Kuzelbas and Andy Liveston in MD Anderson.
This is two basket trial. One of them is for myeloma, the other
one for sarcoma. Is dose escalation studies.
Here, I'm just going to show us the first patient that we treated with NK
TCR
against NY-ESO-1.
After we had all pre-IND work.
This is the 64-year-old with the multiple
myeloma, is
IgA kappa subtype. And then
he has selected DEL17P with the
4;14,
and bone marrow is around 41% plasma cells.
This is the high-risk disease and double hit myeloma.
And he failed the sixth line of treatment, including autologous
stem cell transplantation, BCMA CAR T cells, and the T-cell
engagers.
We just give this patient after lymphodepletion, only 22 million
TCR NK cells. And then you can see in the first
week of this treatment, the kappa lambda free
chain is going down. And then when you look at the
bone marrow
before the treatment, his bone marrow is
full of the plasma cells with the positivity of CD138
and NY-ESO-1 positive.
After one month
treatment, you can see there is no evidence of disease, CD138
positivity or NY-ESO-1 positivity.
So this patient now, I think is around two years out there with the
complete remission without any evidence of
the relapse.
And then what is really important, we didn't see any CRS,
ICANS or no GvHD or no infusion-related toxicities.
So as a conclusion, this is our first-in-class TCR NK cell
platform, shows
really strong cytotoxicity without any concern of the
safety. And these are off-the-shelf product, and you
can infuse this as an outpatient setup.
And then they're really highly scalable and cost-efficient.
And now we're trying to expand our pipeline with more
antigen, including KRAS, P53, and
MAGE-A3.
With that, I want to thank All Cell Therapy
Institute, leading by Dr. Kate Rezvani, all
my colleague, funding, and my team.
And I will be happy to take any question. Thank you.
Thank you. We have time for a few questions.
Please come to microphone if you have any questions.
I guess I'll start with one. Have you looked at any
persistence of NK TCR in the patients you treated?
Well, for this patient,
just like the all-allergenic product that we have selected,
it was the first dose. Is the 22 million TCR NK
cells. You're seeing this after a certain level, like around day
14, day 28, we've seen this really good population of engraftment, but after that,
we didn't see. But this is the dose level one.
We hope, with which
also you're seeing the patient is two years after
infusion, you're not seeing just any sign of naturally just like how much you
needed selected this.But with our other program,
just
to cite, most of our current case from CD19 trial,
you can see from CD70 trial, we've seen just beyond two years,
just
the evidence of current case in the periphery.
But for this particular patient, we didn't seem, is
beyond day 40.
Very nice talk. I was just wondering, your TCR engineered
NK cell requires presumably MHC1 expression to be recognizing
the tumor cell. And traditionally, MHC1 and 2 are thought to
inhibit NK cell cytotoxicity and function.
Do you think that's playing in here?
Well,
yeah, we never did select
with MHC class one, but we cannot do them select.
My select, yeah, I didn't even...
Might be. Yeah,
I don't think so. This is select, but I think this is the antigen-dependent
one, in cross-linking select the antigen, I think they're going to activate in
cases. There's the balance between inhibitor and activation.
Yeah, I think it's a good question.
And on the flip side of that, can you use that to your advantage?
So do you see that tumor cells that have lost MHC1 expression are still
killed by the NK cell-
Yes
... dodges?
That's a good question. Actually, this is what...
Yeah, in the first selected patient, we see we didn't seem selected downregulation
of MHC class 1.
Yeah.
Very nice
work. So you think the
NK TCR, you think it works better than NK
CAR?
And maybe this one first.
Well,
yeah, I think,
we cannot select, have head-to-head the comparison.
But we have select another platform.
Actually, we did select some kind of
experiment that we have head-to-head comparison that we call the plural-link
NK cells. Since selected this, they don't have a lot of tonic
signal. We do believe, select, they have selected some kind of
superiority. But to say something is going to be so
difficult, actually.
So another quick question is, this is allogeneic trial,
so you treated the first patient two years ago-
Yeah
... who showed really remarkable complete response.
But then,
was there a reason that you couldn't treat any additional patients?
No, we do select treat additional patient.
I think now we have selected five patient, out of five patient, we have
selected three respond. The second patient also first was very good
partial response, then it's turned to complete response.
And the third patient is the partial response.
Last two patient, they were so resistant, patient with a lot of
plasma cells in the bone marrow. They didn't respond. It was actually stable.
I'm not going to say this is not response, but yes, we keep
recruiting the patients.
So then the last two patients also relapsed after
PCMA CAR T treatment?
The two of them, they still am select in remission, but one of them relapsed, the
one that have the partial response.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Hey.
Great talk. This is Dr. Hamadi from Mayo Clinic.
So,
it was fascinating to see that
TCR NK kill faster than TCR T
cells. So I'm just curious about the biology behind it.
Is it their killing capacity?
Yeah, I think this is the well-known that in case that they don't
need selected prior, like
the sensation that they can recognize selected tumor.
This is the main point. That's why we're trying to keep them
select. They retain in case cells cytotoxic machinery
that they can recognize. This the pathway in KG2D, NKG2,
NCR receptor, and the DNAM receptor that they can quickly
activate in case they engage and activate, and they kill the...
They can release the granules, and they kill the tumor.
Impressive. And how about the adverse event?
I saw that you show there is less adverse event,
so any concern
in the long term or?
No, we do not. Actually, as
a cell therapy institute, we have around 15 to 20 clinical trial with
a different setup of disease.
Most of them, we've not seen any side effect,
including Mr. ICANS, CRS or no GVT.
Okay. Impressive. Thank you.
Sure.
Thank you. Well, and for me to move on to the next presentation.
Thank you for your talk.
Thank you.
All right.
Next, we'll welcome Dr. Alexander Eben from
Stanford University,
who will be presenting on universal T cell therapy screening library and
preclinical models of CAR T cell therapy.
Hello.
Thank you for the introduction, and thanks for the opportunity to
speak. I'll just clarify, I'm a post-bac trainee, so
not a doctor yet, but I'm really grateful for the opportunity
to speak and share some of our work with you all.
I'm currently a post-bac trainee at the Stanford University School of Medicine in
both the Roth lab and also the Goode lab.
So the work that I'll be talking about today is largely a collaborative effort
between these two
groups.Maybe
unsurprisingly, I have no financial relationships to
disclose.
But maybe just to start off by talking about the general problem statement that
a lot of our work has been motivated by.
CAR T therapies currently in clinic don't necessarily
induce a durable remission at a six-month time point for the
majority of patients for whom they are approved.
And so a lot of work is being done in this exploratory T-cell engineering
space to try and handle this problem, but usually in very
standardized in vitro protocols.
And so it requires a bit of translation to actually get to meaningful
results that make a difference in patient outcomes.
So we thought, what if we start with patient data in
mind? We're specifically interested in immunosuppression
that patients who are administered CAR T products might see in the clinic, and
the genotypes within these patients that may correspond to a
poor-performing infusion product.
And we want to test these products in assays in the lab that are better
approximations of the actual patient biology, which could
mean things like in vivo work, but also in vitro assay
optimization through the addition of things like soluble
immunosuppressive cytokines like TGF-beta, but
also co-culture assays with things like cultured CAR
T-regs, for example.
So our work within this project is largely focused on
standard of care axicell, which is a FDA-approved therapy,
a CD19-targeted CAR therapy for patients with relapse and
refractory large B-cell lymphoma.
And so I've included here a cell atlas snapshot or a picture of the few
studies we've included in what we've termed our T-cell data warehouse,
that is focused on this specific treatment modality.
And the main question we're trying to answer in both assembling and analyzing these
data sets, and building machine learning or deep learning models that are
trained on these data sets is what genes can we manipulate
in our lab protocols and screens to move engineered
cells towards what we would consider a more effective responder
state or a more effective patient infusion product?
And so training and validating these models requires a
screening platform that enables combinatorial perturbations.
So we're jointly able to model a CAR construct, but
also multiple gene edits within the same screen, and this is where
the technology CRISPR-all comes in.
So CRISPR-all has kind of been the hallmark project of the Roth lab,
and it's essentially a multiplexable Cas12a-directed
non-viral perturbation technology for use in primary
human T cells.
And so a portion of the lab is focused on using this technology, specifically
domain shuffling approaches, to arrive at evolved or
synthetic genes. But for this project in particular, because again, we're starting
with patient data in mind, we're focused more on
endogenous genes.
But essentially, as I was mentioning earlier, patients who respond
or don't respond or fail to respond to CAR T therapy likely
differ not because of a single gene being turned on or off,
but more likely because of complex combinations of genetic states
within their T cells. So CRISPR-all is a really wonderful technology in
terms of
it allowing us to screen all of these perturbation types
simultaneously, rather than having to run separate
CRISPRa, I, or knockout screens, for example, for each sort of
modality we're interested in. And so this framework is what we used
for the library that I'll describe in the coming slides.
But just to go into a little bit more detail about the actual CRISPR
architecture itself, we have a uniform plasmid backbone
that integrates via homology directed repair into the endogenous trac
locus of primary human T cells. And so the idea
is that after a few rounds of simple digestions and ligations, you're
able to generate a single HDRT or homology-directed
repair template that contains multiple perturbations.
And the ease of this process allows it to be scaled rapidly, making
combinatorial pooled knockin screenings easier than ever before.
And so I guess just to go back to my initial slide, we've
identified genetic signatures in responders versus non-responder
infusion products from patients, and CRISPR-all allows us to take those
signatures, which involve, as I mentioned, changes across multiple
perturbation classes and functionally test them in a pooled screen.
And so this work is out as a preprint right now.
I would encourage you all to take a look.
But a large part of this work also included putting together what we've termed the
CRISPR-all Cell Therapy Universal Screening Library, or abbreviated
as CACTUS.
And you can see all of the component libraries that are included,
things like FDA-approved CARs, the five FDA-approved CARs, but also things
like synthetic genes, but also targets for knockouts and knockdowns.
But with 636 individual members, it's essentially a catalog
of all of the kinds of genetic differences that could
distinguish one CAR T-cell product from another, making it a
natural
fit for asking the question of which genetic configurations
produce infusion products that look more like those from responders versus
those who fail to respond. And so this is what I would term the
base CACTUS library for this presentation.
And so I've included some of our initial results from the base CACTUS library
here,
and there's a lot more in the preprint, so I would encourage you to take a
look.But we've also, thanks to work from
Zena Good and then also the Marcel Mas group in 2022,
we have a better idea of specific genes that are important to pay attention
to in infusion products that may actually be correlates of
response in the disease setting of large B-cell lymphoma.
And that's what makes up this first library iteration of what I've
termed CACTEX2 in the rest of this presentation.
So you can see the 34 additional members towards the right of the slide
that have been informed by this clinical data set analysis.
And again, the cloning of this multi-perturbation class library was really made
possible through the facile design and architecture of the
Crispr-all workflow.
But just to talk a little bit about the screens that we ran with this library and
also with the Crispr-all architecture, we used a
chronic stimulation assay,
but we first isolated primary human T cells from two healthy
donors, and then through non-viral TRAC knock-in,
electroporated these T cells with our CACTEX2
library. So that's our input cell population.
And then we took these cells through a repetitive stimulation assay, which is
essentially co-culturing them against a target cell line.
In this case, it was Toledo cells, which are a lymphoma cell line.
And we did that for six repetitive simulations, and also did that at
two different effector-to-target ratios, a one to four and a one to
eight ratio. And then at both the input and output time point,
we collected or isolated genomic DNA, which allows
us to perform NGS-driven barcode readout of
input and outputs and generate log two fold change values.
And this is kind of the base level analysis that is empowered by the
Crispr-all architecture as each perturbation is linked to about an
11 base pair barcode.
And so just to talk about a little bit of the initial hits we saw from these
early screens, we tend to see a lot of these synthetic hits proliferating the
best across multiple screens that the lab has run.
So things like synthetic chimeras, like FAS OX40,
for example. But we also see things that might make sense given T cell
biology, like successful proliferation of factors like
TCF7L1 and other markers of T cell
stemness. This is just one of the many screens that the lab has
run. In our preprint, we also have screen results from a library we've termed
our combo CACTEX screens, which features a library
exclusively of multi-perturbation constructs.
So I would encourage you to take a look at the preprint if you're interested in
more of that work, and more of the synthetic work as well.
But in these initial screens, in vitro screens that we ran specifically with this
CACTEX2 library against the Toledo cell line, we also saw hits
that were specifically unique to a lymphoma model,
like hits from the arid family, for example.
Those were hits that we did not see in other screens that the lab
had run in our NOM6 leukemia cell lines.
And so in future library iterations for this project, we're paring down the number
of synthetic library members, as again, our end goal is to sort of
harmonize this data with our clinical trial data sets.
But we have also run in vivo screens with this library as well,
and as I mentioned in the beginning of the presentation, we're really hoping to
sort of screen our library members in more physiologically relevant
contexts, hence us running an in vivo screen.
But we use the same Toledo lymphoma cell line here, and we allowed
those cells to expand for about three weeks, and then
after which we
injected our CAR T cells or edited CAR T cells via
tail vein injection. Both of those were IV injections, and then after
two weeks, we pulled our mice down, performed
enrichment on a pooled spleen cell suspension from all of our
seven mice, and then performed traditional amplicon sequencing to be
able to generate
similar log two fold change plots.
And so I include this plot here just to show that we
are able to mine, I would say, a significant amount of data from what I would
consider a smaller in vivo scale or a smaller scale in vivo screen
that the lab has run.
But I think more exciting is, as I mentioned earlier, a large part of the project
is also focused on model generation and development, and one of those
models is TCellMill, and to not go into too much detail, it's a deep learning
model that's been trained on the infusion product data that I showed
earlier. And the model is really attempting to sort
of identify what gene signatures might be correlated with patients who
respond to CAR T therapies versus do not.
And I think some really encouraging early work or early results that we've seen
from our work is that we see a large degree of concordance between
results from TCellMill or one of these deep learning models, and also from our in
vitro and in vivo screens. So about 71% of hits are matching in the
same direction, whether those hits are enriched or depleted.
But just to wrap up, I know I'm short on time, but we've essentially done one
full iteration of this loop that I showed at the beginning of the
presentation, which is attempting to link patient insights with
model predictions and functional screens, which will in turn be used for
further single-cell experimentation, driving model generation and
optimization. And so we have some ongoing work
involving perturb-seq experiments with another library that we've
created solely based on the concordant hits between these different screens that I
was talking about. And then also through the Stanford Center for Cell Therapy,
we have access to patient samples that we are actually hoping to take through this
pipeline as well. And then I've included a goal statement which you all can read,
but it's really encouraging work and I'm happy to be able to share this work with
you all. And with that, I would also like to thank all my lab
members, and also our collaborators at Stanford, and please
find me afterwards if you have any questions. Thank you.
Okay. So I'd like to invite Aslan Arnett
up from Baylor College of Medicine.
He'll be discussing Triple Disruption of
CCDC6, ZEB1B, and
ASB2 Promotes the Therapeutic Efficacy of
Glypican-3 Targeted T Cells.
Thanks, everyone.
So today, I'd like to talk to you guys about a unique opportunity
that emerged from our clinical studies that we think can not only teach us about
CAR T cell biology, but also hopefully allow us to bring something
meaningfully back to the clinic.
Just a disclosure, we do have a patent related to this work.
So
we recently reported results from our Glypican-3
targeted IL-15 armored CAR T cells in solid
tumors.
And what we saw from this study was essentially
without any
enhancement, we really didn't see many responses in patients.
However, with the inclusion of IL-15, we started to see meaningful
reductions in tumor burden.
Specifically, we saw a quite impressive
response in this patient that
was a 20-year-old male with HCC or hepatocellular carcinoma.
CT imaging of this patient showed a reduction in tumor burden
both at the primary liver sites as well as
metastases in the lungs.
But what was really quite striking is the
expansion that was also seen in this patient.
So we estimate by flow cytometry that this patient had 14.7 billion
circulating CAR T cells at peak expansion.
This necessitated use of our inducible Caspase-9 safety switch,
as this patient had Grade 3 CRS.
But I think this really
puts into perspective what I showed on the last slide, which is this
tumor reduction occurred in 16 days in this patient.
But what really caught our attention is that the majority of this
response was a clonal expansion. So what I'm showing you here
is
TCR clonotype
identified using 5 prime TCR sequencing with
10X from single-cell RNA seq. And what you can see is
compared to the peripheral blood of other patients treated on this trial, this
patient really uniquely had a large clonal expansion that
we actually couldn't trace back to the infusion product, which suggests that this
came from either a single or very small
expanded clone initially.
To begin to understand what made this patient unique,
we looked back at the flow cytometry at week two, which is our peak
expansion time point, and compared it to other patients in the trial.
And so this patient's denoted by the red dot.
And so the majority of these cells are CD8s.
They express lower levels of TIM-3,
high levels of CD39, low levels of CD69,
and have a T effector memory phenotype.
But to really understand what made this expanded clone different, we had to turn
back to our single-cell RNA sequencing.
So we used the peripheral blood cells
and Seurat-based clustering to identify nine unique clusters, three of
which have the clone of interest overrepresented in clusters
one, four, and eight
which more or less make up this left ring in the UMAP.
If we use Seurat to just annotate cell cycle, you can see that perhaps
unsurprisingly, the majority of the expanded clone cells
are in S or G2M transition phase cell cycle,
with the exception of cluster eight, which is on the other
side of the ring. If we pseudo-bulk
clone one or the expanded clone cells compared to all the other clones in this
patient, we see that the gene programs in this clone
are consistent with a growing and dividing cell,
upregulating genes related to oxidative phosphorylation, protein folding,
and DNA replication.
We can also use GSEA to annotate clusters.
And what you can see is that the
clusters that
have
the clone overrepresented, including one and four, separate by cell
cycle. Actually, the majority are either separated by
S phase or G2M, whereas cluster eight seems to be
more highly
differentiated by regulators of T cell activation.
If we zoom in on some genes of interest,
you can see why these
cells cannot easily be put into traditional T cell differentiation
paradigms.
We can find genes, nevertheless, known to have an effect on T cell
biology. So we can see an increase in
BCL2A1, which is an anti-apoptotic protein,
as well as RUNX2, which has been shown by Terry Fry and others to be important
for CAR T cell and T cell longevity.
And while these are significantly different in cluster eight, you can also see they
trend upwards in clusters one and four.
Whereas in cluster eight alone, we can see upregulation of
ZNF683, which is a homolog of PRDM1 and has been previously
been shown to be important for CAR T cell efficacy, as well
as a T tissue-resident memory
precursor phenotype in the setting of mouse cells.
So to understand mechanistically what drove this clonal expansion, we of course
remembered a story that was referenced in Carl June's plenary, which was
the TET2 story from 2019,
where in that trial, they identified
lentiviral integrations that interrupted...
the TET2 gene in a natural heterozygote null patient
that led to clonal expansion of those cells and complete remission in that
patient. And so we asked whether or not there's integrations in these
cells that closely mirrored the kinetics of our expanded
clone. And sure enough, what we found was that there's three integrations
in genes ASB2, CCDC6, and CBLB that
closely mirrored the kinetics of our expanded TCR clone.
And we've since confirmed using Mission Bio's single-cell DNA sequencing
that all three integrations are in fact in this expanded clone.
To confirm disruption of these loci, we turned again back to our single-cell RNA
sequencing and looked to see if we could find chimeric transcripts wherein
our CAR retroviral insert has
actually disrupted this gene through aberrant splicing.
And what you can see is indeed we can find at that predicted integration
locations, chimeric reads between ASB2 and the
CAR, CBLB and the CAR, and CCDC6 and the IL15
cassette.
We then asked whether or not perturbation or, sorry,
disruption of these loci are sufficient to drive the phenotype that we
saw in these patient cells. And to do this, we used xenograft
models of HCC, which is again, the
indication that this patient had,
and also took advantage of our dual luciferase model, where we can
simultaneously track tumor burden as well as T cell expansion
simultaneously in the same mouse.
And what we're doing here is we're comparing control B2M irrelevant
knockout to triple
knockout CBLB, CCDC6, and ASB2
cells using base editing to disrupt splice donor sites
to similarly
disrupt the loci as we saw in the patient.
And then we're monitoring the mice with bioluminescence
imaging weekly. So first, I'm just going to show you the T cell
expansion data. And compared to
the IL15 B2M control mice,
these are still IL15-enhanced cells.
So you can appreciate there's still an expansion of the T cells.
However, when we
interrupt all three loci, you can see a much greater
expansion in the triple knockout cells.
Consistent with this story, you can see when we look at the tumor burden,
we see some control of the tumor in the B2M
knockout mice. However, we see complete control and
survival of the mice with the triple knockout cells.
And so moving forward, this is an active area
investigation.
We would like to further dissect the mechanism of these triple knockout
IL15 CAR T cells to understand to what extent does this model
recapitulate what we saw in the patient.
We'd also like to ask whether or not disruption of all three of these genes is
required, or whether or not one or two of these serves as a passenger
mutation. And then lastly, this occurred in a patient with IL15 CAR
T cells, but we'd like to ask whether or not IL15 is
required for this expansion and antitumor activity
phenotype or whether or not it's synergistic.
And with that, I'd like to thank my colleagues in the Hexsi Lab.
We've moved to Seattle Children's,
as well as the Mentalita Lab at Texas Children's Hospital, who we collaborate
with closely. Our other collaborators at CAGT and Texas
Children's, as well as the Bushman Lab and the Bashour Lab, and funding
from the NIH and the PhRMA Foundation. And I'd love to take any questions.
Thanks.
Thanks. We have time for a few questions.
Please come to the microphone if you have any questions.
Any insights from other studies as far as
those individual genes that you identified as far as relationship
to
T cell
exhaustion or proliferation?
Yeah. So,
as many in the audience may know, CBLB is a well-described negative regulator
of TCR signaling.
And there's been multiple papers that have shown that knockout of CBLB
may potentiate
T cell-based therapeutics.
There's very little known about or really nothing known about
CCDC6 in T cells. ASB2, there's a few papers that focus on it.
Nothing really in CD8s.
Yeah.
Great talk.
I would like to follow up with CBLB, so my question was about CBLB.
Yeah, it's a famous ubiquitin ligase.
So have you looked at a proximal
TCR molecule? Is there a constitutive
activation of phosphorylation of the proximal molecules?
And
do we have concern in term of this constitutive
activation?
So,
to first address the first part, currently, we've begun
looking at proximal signaling
in the triple knockout. I will say, although the
data's very fresh, that it does seem like we get
at least partial, if not full,
recapitulation of what you would expect from CBLB.
Although in terms of very proximal signaling, so like
ZAP70, that actually doesn't look like it's that
differentUm, between B2M control mice
and, oh, sorry, B2M control cells and
the triple knockout cells. So it actually kind of seems like it's the more distant
activity of Cblb, but that's very kind of fresh data, so we'll have to do
much more work to look at that.
Regarding whether or not it's a concern to have a Cblb
knockout,
in the patient, we don't believe these were transformed cells, which is
kind of different from other clonal expansion that has been reported for CAR T
cells. Also, I don't think there's any
concerns about transformation from Cblb knockout shown in other studies.
So in
natural cases, so humans with mutations in Cblb,
that can cause
issues in the myeloid compartment
specifically. But in this case, this would be
monoallelic knockout in the setting of this patient because it's a single
integration.
If that fully answers your question.
Yes, it is. But I'm mostly thinking of
autoreactivity.
Mm-hmm.
And we know
that knockout Cblb mice develop
autoimmunity because of this hyperreactivation of
TCR.
Yeah. So I think
that's a difficult question to answer, I think with the
data that we have. We don't have anything that makes us concerned at
this point.
That's right. The only answer is to test
Yeah.
And see how it looks. Thank you.
I have one question. That was very nice.
Thank you.
So
looking at the expansion of the
CAR T cells, they keep on going up as the
target disappears. So it looks like the target's gone for a long time as the
CAR T cells are still expanding. So what's the mechanism of that,
and have you tried to re-infuse those into secondary
mice to see if they're cytokine independent, et
cetera?
Yeah. So we haven't tried any re-infusion experiments.
I think a big part of that is what we've noticed with cytokine
enhancement in general is that these cells can persist for a
very long time in mice. And so I think
we perhaps haven't gotten to the point
where
these cells actually had time to collapse again.
What
I can tell you, but we don't yet have very strong data for, is that if
we do these in the absence of tumors, so if we just put these
cells in mice without tumors,
they will persist for a very long time, but they don't expand.
Interesting. Okay. Thank you.
Great.
Awesome.
Thanks.
All right. Well, congratulations to all the presenters.
It'll be very exciting to see how everyone's work continues to evolve
and advance the field of adoptive T cell therapy moving forward.
This mini symposium highlighted how immune effector
cells can be engineered in different ways to treat various solid
tumors, ranging from GI tumors to melanoma to
medulloblastoma.
Alex Yeapen introduced us to CRISPR-all and CACTEX, a
novel technology developed to improve CAR T cell therapeutic
design. Doctors Chi, Heiteneider, and Arnett
presented data describing novel strategies to improve CAR
T cell potency and anti-tumor activity, ranging from gene
disruption to overexpression to armoring CARs
with chemokines and cytokines.
We also learned of unique characteristics of TIL products that
predict clinical efficacy, thanks to single-cell analysis and
longitudinal tracking of T cells post-infusion from Dr. Yang.
And lastly, we learned about the potential of alternative immune cells
such as NK cells and dendritic cells that can be leveraged to
further improve cellular therapies.
We leave today's mini symposium looking forward to the many ways these
studies will be translated clinically to further improve outcomes for
future patients. As this session draws to a close, I would
like to thank my co-chair, Dr. Moyi, for opening this session,
our panel of speakers for their thought-provoking presentations,
ACR for hosting and curating a wonderful program,
and all of you in the audience for attending this mini symposium.
I hope everyone enjoys the rest of the conference. Thank you.